andrew yang was interviewed on cnn about
his new third party the forward party
it really went very very poorly for
andrew yang
and i i i want to kind of make clear as
we get into these clips
i like andrew yang on a personal level
he's been a guest on this program many
times i was interviewing andrew yang
before almost anybody else it might have
been sam harris who interviewed yang
before i did as far as national shows
but we we were early to talk to andrew
yang universal basic income etc i like
the guy
this interview was a disaster now people
who emailed me had two different points
of view
some
like me believed that this interview was
a complete and total disaster because
andrew yang
continues to just not explain what are
the policies of the forward party
others felt that jim acosta the
interviewer bullied andrew yang and did
not treat him well i just don't see that
andrew yang and the forward party keep
saying we're not left or right but
forward and we take the
common sense consensus view on all of
these divisive issues right but you got
to explain what the position is and you
can't just be like well anything goes
here because then you're not really a
party i believe jim acosta did a good
job in this interview let's take a look
at some clips i think this is very bad
for andrew yang and as i've said before
to me the democratic party is too
centrist so when i think of a third
party which i love i want third parties
we need more than two parties and we
need to figure out the right way to to
properly bolster and inject third
parties into the national dialogue i
want something to the left of the
democratic party
andrew yang started the forward party
with some republicans and it looks like
they're basically trying to place it
between the democratic and republican
parties where there is relatively little
space by the way
um and it just
it's not working for me let's take a
listen to the first part of this
interview on both sides but you're gonna
have to come up with policies negative
results right
now yeah but andrew you're gonna have to
have policy uh positions at some point
how does the forward party feel about
roe versus wage should it have been
overturned
well i personally uh think that women's
reproductive rights are fundamental
human rights but the forward party has
uh not left or right but forward stance
on even the most divisive and
contentious issues what is that
yeah what
what does that mean i mean that that
really doesn't make any sense
his personal view is not really the
issue you have a party here and if the
idea is well
rabid anti-choicers are welcome as well
as anybody else but we're going to take
a consensus view does that make any
sense and what is the consensus view
you've got to explain it take a position
on something you don't have to take a
position on something
you can't just say well you know this is
a hot button issue so i'm not going to
take a position on you you know you want
to run the country you're going to have
to make some hard decisions andrew
again the forward party is about that
common sense consensus majority view
which is very clear on abortion it's
clear what about guns right now andrew
yang is correct
there's a very clear consensus view on
abortion by a higher percentage
than at any point during the roe v wade
era
americans believe abortion should be
legal in most cases that's the common
sense consensus view but can he not say
that because the forward party is also
filled with as many or even more
republicans than than democrats
i don't know but this isn't really doing
it for me what about assault climate
change it's actually clear on just about
every issue under the sun should 18 year
olds be able to buy areas
because of the nature of our system
should 18 year olds be able to buy
ar-15s
again the common sense consensus
majority is that there should be some uh
rules around background checks and
access to firearms but we're not getting
any of these things jim because the
two-party system does not need to
deliver it doesn't sound like you're
taking any hard positions it sounds like
you're trading power it sounds like
you're you're sort of a fill in the
blank party you know if if somebody uh
wants a a party with no clear policy
positions you're it but unfortunately in
the real world
in the real world you have to take a
position on something yeah and this was
kind of an issue when i interviewed
andrew yang about the forward party and
i said
he said everybody's welcome
as long as they believe in like two
things
uh about third parties and i asked him
well so are white nationalists welcome
and he said yes as long as they believe
in those couple things that imploded and
later on twitter he had to backtrack and
say actually the white nationalists
aren't welcome i'm just not really
getting this i want third parties
i want a lot of the things that andrew
yang says he wants as well but i'm not
clear that we're getting it through the
forward party here's another clip where
he was asked about his kind of unusual
tweet about
the mar-a-lago search warrant and
again just everything about the answers
is kind of strange presidential
candidate andrew yang he recently helped
form a new political party called
forward alongside two former republican
officials we should know ford also
happens to be the title of his recent
book and andrew thanks very much for
joining us can i ask you about something
that you tweeted about the fbi search
at mar-a-lago you wrote it looks
increasingly like the fbi raid was to
find mishandled classified documents and
not some other doj investigation which
was my first thought mishandling
documents doesn't seem like raid
material it does however seem like
excellent
campaign material for trump and i have
to ask you it sounds like you're you're
letting trump off the hook here uh
taking top secret documents to your
mansion is okay with you uh are you
giving trump a pass
well thanks jim it was a very disturbing
report you just got from dhoni and the
fact is extremism is on the rise
throughout the country uh it's one
reason why we think the forward party is
so vital because we we think there needs
to be
a broad
positive unifying third party movement
but unfor anything that enhances
national security and the rule of law uh
and our hope is that as the attorney
general i'm for anything that enhances
national security that i mean that
isn't that a cop-out like he's basically
saying
if what happened at mar-a-lago enhances
national security then i'm for it but if
it isn't i'm against it like it's it's a
mish-mash
uh and the doj
dig in that the american people get a
lot of the answers that many of us are
eagerly anticipating
but are you saying that i don't think
you answered my question are you saying
that the attorney general had political
motivations
uh with this search
i trust that all of the doj employees
and particularly the fbi agents are
faithful public servants discharging
their their duty
and it it
hurts us all
that uh people are
singling out individuals in the way that
dhoni described it yeah so i guess he's
against fbi agents being violently
targeted uh one last clip and then i'll
give you my thoughts on something
well
where for the common sense consensus
view on guns abortion climate change but
we're not getting like but what are
those views common sense what are those
positions any of those things those are
just sort of fuzzy but those are fuzzy
nebulous it sounds like you came up with
something in a focus group
you know common sense you know middle of
the ground that sounds wonderful that
sounds great but at the end of the day
don't you have to take a position on
something
well the great thing is the american
people know where we want the country to
go and what we know it's i don't know
that that's true
that we need a more dynamic truly
representative system than we're getting
right now which is why the ford party is
growing so quickly tens of thousands of
americans have signed up in all 50
states yeah i don't know i mean tens of
thousands
doesn't actually sound like very much in
a country of 331 million so i don't know
what to tell you guys like this isn't
feeling like
the
electric
injection of a third party
and in my mind it's just sort of like
okay i know where the democratic party
stands and i know where the republican
party stands and i know that although
i'm not a democrat or a republican i'm
mostly voting for democrats because
they're closer to where i stand
if i'm going to consider the forward
party
i need to know what is their policy
position on guns on abortion on taxation
and to say that it's the common sense
consensus view
it's not enough for me to say this is
the movement for me if i'm missing
something if i'm being too hard on
andrew yang let me know you can find me
on twitter at deepakman also a reminder
wednesday august 31st we will be doing a
members only town hall where i will
field questions
for a period of time from our members
it'll be at 6 pm eastern 3 p.m pacific
and you can get uh
exclusive access to the member only town
hall simply by getting a membership at
joinedpakman.com quick break right back
after this
the science has shown us that one of the
ways to achieve consistent deep sleep is
to lower your core body temperature at
night it also is just really
uncomfortable to be too hot when you're
trying to sleep our longtime sponsor
chili sleep makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions that
improve your sleep by keeping you cool
at night chili sleeps cube and uhler
sleep systems are hydro powered mattress
toppers they fit on your existing
mattress and they provide the ideal
sleep temperature
you can keep your bed as cool as 55
degrees or as hot as 115 i like 62
personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
it's fantastic and chili sleep is the
only company on the market doing it like
this
you'll get thirty percent off your new
cube or uhler sleep system at
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is down below